und damit kommen wir zum zusatzpunkt
aktuelle stunde
die fraktion der afg hat eine aktuelle
stunde verlangt zu dem thema lehren aus
den gewaltexzessen in stuttgart zehn für
eine band in der migrations und
sicherheitspolitik ich eröffne die
aussprache und er teile das wort der
fraktionsvorsitzende der afd doch klar
ließ weiter
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren die trümmer in
der stuttgarter innenstadt sind
weggeräumt die scherben der
zertrümmerten schaufenster und
geplünderte geschäfte zusammengefegt
aber der schock sitzt immer noch tief
bei den polizeibeamten die von einem
organisierten mob mit maximaler
brutalität angegriffen und deren
kollegen ins krankenhaus geprügelt
worden
und bei den bürgern deren scheinbar
friedliche stadt über nacht zum
schauplatz von bürgerkriegsähnlichen
szenen wurde nach der stuttgarter
krawallnacht können wir nicht einfach
weiter so tun als gebe es kein
grundsätzliches problem nicht nur
stuttgart jede deutsche großstadt das
ganze land hat ein problem und das
problem heißt nicht rassismus das
problem heißt politikversagen die gewalt
auf den stuttgarter straßen kam nicht
aus heiterem himmel
es war auch keine party und eventszene
die sich der ausgedruckt hat
randalierer und schläger sind keine
party leute sondern kriminelle die hart
bestraft werden sie diese verharmlosung
ist im übrigen eine verhöhnung von
friedlichen partygängern von betreibern
und club besitzern dir unter dem viel zu
lange hat lockdown und den fortgesetzten
corona beschränkungen leiden
der mob der in stuttgart das staatliche
gewaltmonopol herausgefordert und
polizeibeamte als staatliche
hoheitsträger gezielt angegriffen hat
rekrutierte sich aus zwei gruppen
aggressive junge männer mit
migrationshintergrund und organisierte
gewaltbereite linksextremisten
beides ist die frucht falscher
verantwortungslose politik praktisch
unbegrenzte und unkontrollierte
einwanderung hat dazu geführt dass es in
vielen deutschen großstädten inzwischen
ein kritisches potenzial an jungen
männern vornehmlich aus dem islamisch
orientalischen kultur kreis gibt die den
deutschen staat und die
mehrheitsgesellschaft mehr oder minder
offen verachten
dazu kommt die politische und zum teil
sogar mit staatsgeld finanzierte
verhetzung linksradikaler gruppen die
sich als kämpfer gegen rechts tarnen und
das hat die entstehung eines
organisierten und militanten
linksextremen milieu es begünstigt das
den rechtsstaat offen herausfordert und
rechtsfreie räume für sich beansprucht
eine mehrheit in diesem haus hat sich
erstmal wenigen wochen geweigert einem
verbot linksterroristische antifagruppen
zuzustimmen
die stuttgarter krawallnacht ist auch
eine von vielen quittung die dafür noch
ausgestellt werden
und sie ist eine quittung
für die beispiellose zündelei die in den
letzten wochen noch zusätzlich über
dieses land gegangen ist die geistigen
brandstifter sind vor allem auf der
grün-roten seite des politischen
spektrums zu finden leider auch in
diesem haus und das beweisen sie gerade
dort wo man sich unreflektiert zu
sogenannten antifa bekennt und den
linksextrem und rechts staatsfeindlichen
hintergrund dieser fragwürdigen eine
fragwürdige bewegung leugnet und wo man
die polizei und sicherheitskräfte
demontiert indem man ihn pauschal
rassismus vorwirft und sie unter
generalverdacht stellt dieses
verantwortungslose gerede muss von all
jenen die diesen staat und seine
rechtsordnung ablehnen mit und ohne
migrationshintergrund mit und ohne
deutschen pass geradezu als ermunterung
verstanden werden den aufstand und dem
bürgerkrieg zu proben sowie wegen
gesehen haben
ein staat ein staat der die sicherheit
seiner bürger nicht mehr gewährleisten
und recht und gesetz nicht überall und
jederzeit durchsetzen kann das kind
seine legitimation unsere polizeibeamten
brauchen für diese aufgabe mehr als nur
lippenbekenntnisse und genesungswünsche
sie brauchen volle politische
rückendeckung und das heißt auch eine
politik die sich unvoreingenommen gegen
jeden extremismus stellt der rechtsstaat
und öffentliche ordnung angreift und die
jenen die das gastrecht missbrauchen und
den staat und seine hoheitsträger
angreifen des landes verweist
tatsachen und fehlentwicklungen offen
anzusprechen ist der erste schritt um
die rechtsstaatliche ordnung wieder in
vollem umfang durchzusetzen
die stuttgarter krawallnacht war auch
ein weckruf damit endlich anzufangen
ich bedanke mich
[Applaus]
nächster redner ist der kollege thorsten
frei cdu csu herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das was wir am
vorvergangenen wochenende in stuttgart
erlebt haben ist bedauerlicherweise ja
nicht nur ein einzelfall sondern wir
erleben dass immer wieder in städten wie
berlin in leipzig in hamburg wenn es
beispielsweise um die silvesternacht
geht oder wenn es um die erste meine
echte geht werden sie erlebt 2017 in
hamburg beim g-20-gipfel und wir haben
es erlebt 2015 in frankfurt bei der
eröffnung der ezb
das was wir in stuttgart in der nacht
vom 20
auf den 21 juni gesehen haben war
insofern etwas besonderes als es an
einem äußeren anlass ganz offenkundig
gefehlt und trotzdem war da etwas was
uns täglich ist wenn vier bis 500
jugendliche und heranwachsende
marodierend plündernd brandschatzend
durch die stuttgarter innenstadt ziehen
dann ist es nicht akzeptabel dann
brauchen wir eine klare antwort des
rechtsstaates weil wir es nicht zulassen
dürfen dass menschen die sich so
verhalten dem rechtsstaat auf der nase
herumtanzen
und es geht um menschen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
es geht darum dass dort
schaufensterscheiben ein geschmissen
worden sind in einer zeit wo wir die
wirtschaftlichen folgen der pandemie
bekämpfen wo einzelhändler und familien
ohnehin versuchen die nase über dem
wasser zu halten
und da werden millionenschäden
angerichtet allein ein kiosk muss
renoviert werden für 100000 euro die
einnahmeausfälle gar nicht mitgerechnet
so etwas ist unverantwortlich und
deshalb brauchen wir eine klare antwort
genauso wie auf die attacken auf
polizisten die behandelt werden als
während sie keine menschen das ist
inakzeptabel und es fallen
die volle rückendeckung des staates und
der staatlichen organe wenn es um unsere
polizei gehen ich finde an der stelle
sind zwei dinge richtig und notwendig
erstens wir müssen genau analysieren was
da passiert ist wer war das
was waren das für kuchen haben wir einen
politischen hintergrund oder haben sie
es nicht wie sind die organisiert
gewesen
das müssen wir beantworten und deswegen
möchte ich einfach auch an ihre adresse
frau kollegin weiter sagen ich halte es
für falsch und fahrlässig zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt wo wir all diese fragen nicht
beantworten können
vermutungen in den raum zu stellen die
die dinge nicht besser machen sondern im
gegenteil schlechter ich finde das
sollten wir abwarten das sollten wir
überprüfen und dann gibt es zum zweiten
punkte die kann man auch ungeachtet
dessen heute bereits sagen erstens
kommunale kriminalitätsprävention etwas
was das sicherheitsgefühl der menschen
verstärkt das ist etwas was die pflicht
jeder guten kommunalpolitik ist und wenn
es in stuttgart so ist dass es im
schlossgarten bereiche gibt die no go
areas sind wenn es bereiche gibt die
nicht ausgeleuchtet sind wenn es
bereiche gibt wo man beispielsweise die
möglichkeiten die sich aus der
videoüberwachung ergeben nicht nutzt
wenn man die möglichkeiten die aus der
zeitlich und örtlich begrenzten
alkoholverbote sich ergeben nicht nutzt
wenn man die angebote der baden
württembergischen landesregierung eine
sicherheitspartnerschaft aufzulegen
anders als alle anderen
baden-württembergischen großstädten
nicht nutzt dann ist es etwas was aus
meiner sicht schon mal nicht akzeptabel
ist das ist der erste punkt wo man
niedrigschwellig das sicherheitsgefühl
und auch die objektive sicherheitslage
für die menschen deutlich verbessern
kann
das zweite
gerade wenn es um jugendliche und
heranwachsende straftäter geht muss der
rechtsstaat glaubwürdig sein und wie es
war glaubwürdig mich dem thema rohmeyer
sondern in dem die strafe auf dem fuß
folgt und das bedeutet dass man die
möglichkeiten des beschleunigten
verfahrens wie wir sie heute in der
strafprozessordnung haben eben auch
tatsächlich einsetzt und das ganze dem
motto folgt heute auf morgen
das ist etwas was die jungen leute die
so etwas machen dann vielleicht auch
verstehen und der dritte punkt den ich
ansprechen möchte wir sollten uns schon
genau anschauen ob wir auch was die
möglichkeiten des strafrechts anbelangt
richtig sortiert sind oder wenn der ein
oder anderen stelle vielleicht
nachbessern sollten ich will zwei punkte
nennen
die tätlichen angriffen auf
polizeibeamte insbesondere dann wenn sie
schwere gesundheitsschäden davontragen
aber auch der widerstand gegen
vollstreckungsbeamte
ich bin dafür dass insbesondere wenn
polizisten zu schweren körperlichen und
gesundheitlichen schaden kommen wie die
mindeststrafe auf zwölf monate erhöhen
und damit das ganze zum verbrechen
machen das wäre ein klares die redet
regel der redezeit regel der aktuellen
stunde sind streng ihre fünf minuten
sind vorüber ich habe in hettstadt
redner ist der kollege benjamin strasser
fdp ich danke ihnen für die
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die
krawallnacht von stuttgart hat ein
gewaltpotenzial in einer demission
offenbar das in meiner heimat in
baden-württemberg bisher seinesgleichen
sucht wir haben ein kontrollverlust
staatliches des staatlichen
gewaltmonopols erlebt das bisher
seinesgleichen sucht fünf stunden lang
hat es gedauert bis in stuttgart die
öffentliche ordnung wieder hergestellt
worden ist fünf stunden in denen
polizisten zu freiwild erklärt worden
sind in dem geschäfte geplündert wurden
und in denen unbeteiligte bürgerinnen
und bürger verbal aber auch körperlich
angegriffen wurden
diese täter haben ein widerwärtiges und
schändliches verhalten offenbart ist
meine fraktion in tiefer abscheu
verurteilt liebe kollegen der polizei
den rücken stärken das wurde
richtigerweise in den vergangenen tagen
von unterschiedlichen fraktionen in
diesem haus gesagt dahinter versammeln
wie raus aber es darf auch keine leere
worthülse werden
wer in einer wichtigen rassismus debatte
in unserem land einseitig und
stigmatisieren die polizei in eine ecke
stellen die der spd-vorsitzende esken
der stadt der polizei eben nicht den
rücken
wer mit schaum vor dem mund thesen
vertritt wie wir es gerade gehört haben
der stärkt der polizei nicht den rücken
wer aber auch scheuklappen aufsetzt und
ursachen nicht sehen will die dazu
geführt wo haben der stadt der polizei
eben auch nicht den rücken sondern wir
stärken der polizei den rücken wenn man
sachlich aufklärt was tatsächlich
geschehen ist und die notwendigen
konsequenzen zieht liebe kollegen
kollegen und diese sachliche aufklärung
die habe ich durchaus bei
verantwortlichen für mich da war die
sprache von partyszene eine partyszene
die für diese taten verantwortlich
gewesen sein soll liebe kollegen ich war
als junger mann auch mal teil dieser
stuttgarter partyszene ich kann ihnen
sagen die trifft sich nicht am eckensee
in stuttgart die trifft sich in der
theodor start
straße oder bei man von im glück brunnen
oder woanders aber umso mehr hätte ich
mir schon gewünscht dass gerade der
grüne oberbürgermeister kuhn hier mal
ein wort spricht er sollte eigentlich
die verhältnisse kennen und dass dieser
mensch weißt dass das zeigt auch eine
bestimmte einstellung weil dieses wort
von partyszene ja nicht nur junge
menschen diskreditiert die friedlich
feiern wollen sondern weil es ein
problem verharmlost das aus meiner sicht
besteht in stuttgart peinlich und
unprofessionell war aber vor allem der
innenminister des landes baden
württemberg thomas strobl der sich in
einem swr interview zu wort meldet und
sagt zitat ich habe mich schon im
letzten jahr darüber gewundert was sich
gerade in den abendstunden dort zitat
ende
wir fragen uns was hat eigentlich thomas
strobl im vergangenen jahr gemacht wo
war der neue anlauf einer
sicherheitskooperation in stuttgart er
hat schlicht und einfach die hände in
den schoß gelegt und damit die
polizistin in stuttgart im stich
gelassen liebe kollegen und das geht ja
noch weiter
strobl vor einigen tagen in der
stuttgarter nach dem zitat da ist alles
dabei vom betrunkenen bis zum
gewalttätigen linksextremisten die
linksextremisten hätten keine
untergeordnete rolle gespielt so strobl
das ist ja ein alarmierender befund und
wir haben wir haben mal nachgefragt bei
der bundesregierung im unterausschuss
was sind denn das für
linksextremistische gruppen die dahinter
stehen antwort wir haben keine
erkenntnisse
das land baden württemberg hat momentan
keine erkenntnisse lieber herr strobel
wenn sie erkenntnisse besitzen dann
müssen sie sie offenlegen und wenn sie
keine haben dann gebietet es dass ein
minister sich nicht an mythenbildung
beteiligt sondern faktenbasierte
aufklärung der vorwürfe vor an trink
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen 37 von
500 tatverdächtigen sind ermittelt und
es ist klar wir sind ab anfang der
aufklärung und wir war erwarten dass
alle diese 500 personen zur rechenschaft
gezogen werden und wir müssen auch
unterschiedlichen ebenen ansetzen das
klar geworden herr frey hat einige
punkte genannt was die stadt stuttgart
angeht aber zur wahrheit gehört auch
wenn die polizei in stuttgart
beispielsweise die fehlende
schutzausrüstung bemängelt
im einsatz dann ist nicht die stadt
stuttgart verantwortlich sondern der
innenminister strobl
wenn wir zu wenige richter und
staatsanwalt stellen haben in baden
württemberg damit die strafe auf dem fuß
folgen kann dann ist nicht die stadt
stuttgart verantwortlich dann ist
innenminister guido wolf von der cdu
verantwortlich bin kollegen und wir
müssen uns auch im bund die frage
stellen wo können wir besser werden
beispielsweise beim thema von
abschiebungen vollziehbare
ausreisepflichtige 16 personen der
tatverdächtigen haben keinen deutschen
pass und da müssen wir genau hinschauen
an was es gelegen hat
aber alles in allem es ist ein
gesellschaftliches problem dem wir uns
stellen müssen und da helfen auch keine
strafverschärfung von normen sondern da
hilft eine gesellschaftliche debatte
der rechtsstaat täglich anfordert und
arenen redezeit ist jetzt auch
abgelaufen und das know how bieten die
kollegin ute vogt spd herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen herr
kollege strasser ist ein bisschen schade
dass sie das jetzt so eine art wahlkampf
rundumschlag und jeder kriegt eine
mitnutzen ich finde wir sollten uns eher
um das thema kümmern um das es hier in
der debatte gehen soll und vor allem um
diejenigen kümmern die an diesem
wochenende den kopf für uns hingehalten
haben nämlich die polizistinnen und
polizisten
ich habe am montag nach diesen
ausschreitungen die gelegenheit im
polizeipräsidium auch mit denen zu reden
die direkt im einsatz dabei gewesen sind
und wenn man sich diese bilder anschaut
und sich vor augen hält dass es eine
streife war mit zwei ganz normal
ausgestatteten polizisten und die zu
zweit einfach auf kontrolle waren wie
sie das jeden abend dort machen und die
zwei dann wirklich angegriffen wurden
aus dem nichts heraus quasi und dann
sehr schnell kolleginnen und kollegen zu
hilfe
carmen und dann 45 beamtinnen und beamte
eine halbe stunde lang da standen und
mit pflastersteinen beworfen wurden
dann muss man wirklich sagen allererste
pflicht von uns ist es zu danken denen
die da standen die angegriffen wurden
die keine ausrüstung hatten weil sie
nicht zur ausrüstung des abends gehört
hatten und die trotzdem so besonnen
waren dass sie keinen warnschuss und
keine exzesse daraus entstanden sind ich
finde dass es mit große leistung in so
einer situation ruhig zu bleiben und
diese polizistinnen und polizisten die
haben es nicht verdient dass man da auf
ihrem rücken politische spielchen
austrägt sondern die haben es verdient
dass wir uns ernsthaft gedanken machen
ernsthaft gedanken machen wo kommen
solche gewaltexzesse her und diese
gewaltexzesse haben eben keine
eindimensionale begründung und es waren
eben ganz viele unterschiedliche
menschen die polizei hat an dem am
nächsten tag uns verkündet es waren vor
allem viele männer viele junge männer
viele betrunkene und alkoholisierte
männer
aber sie waren aus allen schichten der
gesellschaft und sie waren auch aus
allen unterschiedlichen herkunft also in
diesem sinne ist sicherlich ein punkt
den der kollege frei gesagt hat strafen
ermitteln bestrafen und das ganz schnell
ein zweiter punkt ist aber auch dass wir
uns um die kümmern müssen die darum
standen die geholfen haben die nicht
eingegriffen haben die nicht am lasst es
sein sondern die noch dabei gestanden
sind denn sie sich die filme anschauen
die stehen da dabei und schauen zu und
nicht weniger zügen des handy die jungs
passieren zum teil die mädels aber auch
andere jungs die filmen die dabei und
das müssen wir auch ins auge nehmen das
ist eine kranke entwicklung so was dass
man sich an gewalt erfreut die postet
und dafür noch leisten kommt in unserer
gesellschaft
und das sind genau so wichtige
diskussionen wie die frage der der
bestrafung der straftäter die wir der
wir hoffentlich alle habhaft werden
in diesem sinne ist es jetzt notwendig
zu überlegen was sind die einzelnen
maßnahmen kommunale kriminalprävention
will ich ihnen ausdrücklich recht geben
die frage was hat man für ein
beleuchtungskonzept aber auch die frage
welche alternativen haben die leute dort
für alle die jetzt stuttgart nicht so
kennen es ist ja so dass da an dem an
dem eckensee kommen die leute abends hin
haben mehrere kästen bier dabei setzen
sich hin haben eine eigene musik dabei
und in jeder ecke ist eine gruppe die
irgendwie der eigenen szene zugehört und
deshalb müssen wir uns auch überlegen
die kommen wir an dir an die machen wir
den platz sicher wie nehmen wir auch zum
beispiel videoaufnahmen an bestimmten
schwierigen stellen vor
aber auch natürlich wie kommen wir ins
gespräch mit den leuten denn es ist eine
staatsferne die da deutlich wird wer
polizei angreift er greift auch den
demokratischen rechtsstaat kann um
deshalb ist es für uns auch eine aufgabe
an dieser stelle klar zu machen wir
dürfen es nicht dulden aber wir müssen
mit den leuten ins gespräch kommen damit
wir merken wie immer irgendwie
eingreifen nicht warten bis es wieder
explodiert und deshalb ist für unsere
fraktion ist eine besonders wichtige
aufgabe dass wir an dieser stelle mit
vielen unterschiedlichen maßnahmen
zusammen arbeiten und wir haben seit
jahren schon versucht auch gesetzlich
mit strafen hier zu reagieren das
alleine hat nicht genutzt deshalb
brauchen wir diese vielfalt von
maßnahmen und da gehört auch selbst wenn
es die afg höhnisch erwähnt natürlich
eine mobile sozialarbeiter zu weil wir
müssen mit den leuten in kontakt kommen
und ein positives verhältnis zum staat
wieder herstellen
bulut die linke ist die nächste rednerin
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen in der letzten
debatte vor der sommerpause möchte die
afg wieder einmal ihre rassistische
hetze auf die tagesordnung setzen
thema dieses mal sind die ereignisse in
der stuttgarter nacht vom 21
juni aber wir alle wissen ja ganz genau
das ist der afg wieder und rassistische
hetze und vor allem auch unfähig news
geht wenn sie hier von nie dagewesener
gewalt in stuttgart sprechen da möchte
ich sie auch an den schwarzen donnerstag
2010 in stuttgart erinnern
schauen sie sich auch mal die bilder von
damals an ihn fällt einfach nichts neues
an man könnte sie einfach umbenennen in
die rassistische alternative für
deutschland dann mehr haben sie auch
nichts zu bieten sie instrumentalisieren
heute ereignisse und machen hier ganze
menschengruppen sündenbock ihrer politik
die mit gewalt nichts zu tun haben
schauen sie sich auch noch mal die
pressekonferenz der stuttgarter polizei
an die da auch ganz differenziert
berichtet und vor allem hätten sie auch
in der sitzung des innenausschusses
diese woche mal auch besser zugehört
dann wüssten sie auch das unter den 37
beschuldigten über die hälfte deutsche
sind auch original uhr oder auch wieder
deutsche wie sie es auch immer
bezeichnen möchte es waren ging es waren
gemischte jugendgruppen die polizei
spricht auch von einer heterogenen
gruppe wenn sie nicht mal der polizei
glauben dann ist das ihr problem
angesichts eines migrationsanteil von 45
prozent in der stuttgarter bevölkerung
ist diese zusammensetzung auf normalen
für sie ist es auch egal dass die
kontrolle eines deutschen jugendlichen
ausgangspunkt für die ereignisse am 21
juni war aber hauptsache sie können
wieder über migrantische jugendliche her
ziehen
wir verurteilen natürlich jede form von
gewalt und auch die zerstörung von
geschäften
oder auch plünderungen und fordern eine
umfassende aufklärung ereignisse in
dieser nacht es haben sicherlich eine
rolle von vielen verschiedenen faktoren
dazu geführt dass es zu dieser zu dieser
entwicklung gekommen ist aber all das
müssen noch ausgearbeitet werden
für uns ist natürlich wichtig dass diese
situation sich nicht wiederholt aber
härteres durchgreifen mehr
polizeipräsenz ausweitung der
polizeibefugnisse mehr videoüberwachung
et cetera werden wenig zu der lösung der
probleme der jugend beitragen
wichtig ist sich die ursachen genauer
anzuschauen vor allem aber auch
präventive maßnahmen zu ergreifen wie
zum beispiel ist ritual k programmen die
aber 2012 2013 aus dem stuttgarter
haushalt gestrichen worden sind
viele sozialarbeiter und auch
multiplikatoren in der jugendarbeit
liegen die rufe nach mehr law & order
und nach mehr härte gegen die bei
jugendlichen ab die lokal und
fachpolitik scheint viel sachlicher mit
der thematik umzugehen wie die weit
entfernte bundespolitik heute hier in
stuttgart ist viel von partizipation
aufklärung dialog und integration die
rede
das ist auch der richtige schritt in die
richtige richtung die afg ist aber weit
davon entfernt ein interesse daran zu
haben dass sich die situation vor ort
für alle verbessert viele jugendliche
mit einem sogenannten
migrationshintergrund werden weiterhin
tagtäglich opfer von rassismus und
diskriminierungen
dazu gehören auch polizei praktiken wie
racial profiling hilfe gibt es auch
zahlreiche studien unter anderem auf
studien des deutschen instituts für
menschenrechte
rassismus ist leider auch in den
behörden und auch innerhalb der polizei
strukturen kein verein zieht das problem
sondern ein strukturelles problem was
wir ansprechen und angehen müssen
deshalb fordern wir mehr studien mehr an
und und mehr aufarbeitung und vor allem
auch unabhängige beschwerdestelle de
betreibt mit ihrem rassistischen diskurs
weiterhin ein gefährliches spiel für die
spaltung unserer gesellschaft dabei ist
sie selbst die größte gefahr und vor
allem das größte sicherheitsrisiko in
unserer gesellschaft
s p geht keine woche es vergeht keine
woche in der wir nicht davon hören dass
wieder ein neonazi entdeckt wurde der
für die afg arbeitet der bundesrat
bundestagsabgeordnete rené springer hat
einen neonazi eingestellt der einer
rechtsextremen treffer gruppe angehört
die sich auf einen rassenkrieg
vorbereitet und sich dafür auch befasst
hat sie sind der politische arm solcher
rechtsextremer terrorgruppen die größte
gefahr geht weiterhin von
rechtsextremismus in unserer
gesellschaft aus das weiß auch der
bundesinnenminister
denken wir noch an hana denken wir noch
an hanau
denken wir an gürkan gültekin anstatt
wie bis anzeige nicht rasch in ihren
mercedes kierpiec arnheim panzer kenan
kulturweg video für paul partys karachi
affäre hat irgendwann kalorien welt ob
sie alle sind opfer rassistischen terror
anschlags und ihre namen dürfen wir
nicht vergessen denn das alles ist auf
ergebnis ihrer hetze gewesen
die afg krieg rassistische und
antisemitische abgelaufen und sie haben
jetzt hat das wort der kollege cem
özdemir bündnis 90 die grünen
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren der schock über den
gewaltausbruch von stuttgart sitzt tief
alle gewalttäter gehören die recht
bestraft und zu den anstiftern das
möchte ich schon ausdrücklich sagen
gehören für mich auf all diejenigen die
gewalttaten die kollegin vogler das
bereits erwähnte im netz gefeiert haben
als ob es der heldentat wäre die
schaufenster zu zerstören wodurch
polizisten einzuprügeln
ich möchte möchte ausdrücklich nehmen im
namen aller demokratischen kräfte im
bundestag unseren einsatzkräften von der
polizei unsere feuerwehr und dem thw und
unseren sanitätern danken für ihre
arbeit
es ist aber auch es ist aber auch
unsäglich wenn der geschäftsführer der
stiftung sächsische gedenkstätten im
zusammenhang mit stuttgart von einer
stark zitieren bundes kristallnacht
spricht was für eine unglaubliche
verharmlosung des ns-terrors was für
eine verhöhnung der opfer der ns gewalt
ich hab' ich hab nach den krawallen mit
vielen betroffenen gesprochen mit
unserer polizei mit ladenbesitzerin und
ladenbesitzern mit der mobilen
jugendarbeit jetzt geht es erstmal darum
dafür zu sorgen dass sich so etwas nicht
wiederholt wir werden unsere probleme zu
regeln wie wir das in stuttgart seit
langem überparteilichen gut im geiste
machen wir setzen uns zusammen wir
stellen uns auch selbstkritische fragen
es muss mehr machen wenn so was passiert
ist gar keine frage
wir hören dann dazu und dann ergreifen
wir maßnahmen um einerseits die
sicherheit zu erhöhen und gleichzeitig
auch an die wurzeln des problems zu
gehen nur das bitteschön hat nichts mit
dem zu tun worum es ihnen geht meine
damen und herren wenn ihr
geschäftsmodell
es ist nicht das lösen von problemen
sondern das verbreiten von angst und
hass das wissen sie und wenn sie ehrlich
sind geben sie es zu
sie machen es mal wieder sich sehr
einfach für sie sind einfach die
migranten schuld niemand verschweigt
hier ich glaube alle sind sie hier einig
dass es unter den randalieren auch
männer mit migrantischem hintergrund gab
vor allem aber waren es junge männer das
ist doch das entscheidende
viele davon stark alkoholisiert und dass
man dazu von ihnen nichts hört das
wundert jetzt glaube ich niemanden hier
es sind unsere jugendlichen und jeder
einzelne von ihnen den wir verlieren ist
einer zu viel
besonders perfide wird es wenn dann in
der debatte eine neue kategorie
eingeführt wird nämlich die sogenannten
passt deutschen was solltest du bitte
sein jemand mit dem wir zwar die
staatsbürgerschaft teilen aber dessen
vorfahren vielleicht nicht in der
schlacht am teutoburger wald gegen die
römer mit gekämpft haben meine damen und
herren merken sie eigentlich auf welch
unsägliche tradition sie sich hier
berufen schon einmal wurden in
deutschland bürger ausgebürgert und in
die zugehörigkeit abgesprochen das wird
es mit uns nie wieder geben in diesem
land meine damen und herren ihr
identitaire das geschwätz widert mich an
als identitäts beschaffungsmaßnahmen
reicht mir unser grundgesetz vollkommen
aus das ist die geschäftsgrundlage
unserer republik und nichts anderes
meine damen und herren es muss uns
sorgen bereiten es muss uns sorgen
bereiten bin junge menschen unsere
polizei misstrauen
ich weiß selber wie sie rassismus
anfühlt nsu und rechte umtriebe beim ksk
ich hoffe dass es möglichst wenig junge
leute hören ihre gelächter hier eines
und rechte umtriebe beim ksk haben uns
gezeigt dass wir probleme mit rassismus
bei uniform trägern aber auch bei
menschen ohne uniform haben aber ich
sage auch in aller deutlichkeit die
deutsche polizei ist nicht die
us-polizei und es darf und kann man
nicht gleich sitzen meine damen und
herren
bei uns bei uns darf man bei uns darf
man exekutives handeln auch der polizei
kritisieren ja man darf sogar juristisch
überprüfen
aber erstmal leistet man bitteschön den
anweisungen des polizisten und übrigens
auch der polizisten folge
das muss die regel sein und diejenigen
die den glauben verlieren
und diejenigen die den glauben verlieren
daran dass man durch eigenen fleiß und
durch die hilfe der gemeinschaft ist was
zu etwas zu bringen kann
die müssen wir gewinnen und das dürfen
wir nicht an die polizei delegieren
sondern sind wir alle als gesellschaft
gefordert
meine damen meine herren gewalt beginnt
wo das reden aufhört sagt anna abends in
diesem geiste arbeiten der in stuttgart
liberal respektvoll und erstklassig axel
müller cdu these der nächste redner
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine
lieben kollegen und kolleginnen mein
wahlkreis erstreckt sich auf das gebiet
oberschwaben württembergisches allgäu
und sagt da wo der süden am schönsten
sei die größte stadt des ravensburger
hat 50.000 einwohner ravensburg
stuttgart das sind 180 kilometer distanz
stuttgart hat über 600.000 einwohner
man könnte meinen beide städte liegt
nicht nur räumlich weit auseinander
sondern auch gesellschaftlich doch in
wahrheit ist das anders
am montag dieser woche um 34 morgens hat
sich in ravensburg folgendes ereignet
es fand eine polizeikontrolle stadt
gegenüber einem verkehrsrowdy der
betrunken und hub und mit seinem pkw
durch die stadt vor die streife hielt
ihn an kontrollierte ihn und plötzlich
war sie umringt von zehn personen die
diese maßnahme behinderten und
vermittelt erhielt einer der beamten
einen stoß gegen den kopf mit dem knie
des delinquenten es gelangt er nach
dessen festnahme am nächsten tag wurde
er dem amtsgericht vorgeführt um den
haft zu nehmen
dort traf er allerdings und die beamten
ebenso auf eine menge die sich
zusammengerottet hatte und vor dem
amtsgericht skandierte das ist rassismus
ravensburg stuttgart sind sich räumlich
doch weit entfernt aber gesellschaftlich
offenbar sehr sehr nahe
selbstverständlich nicht in den haag
ausmaßen aber doch in den ursachen der
polizeipräsident von ravensburg hat das
in einem zeitungsinterview und erfolge
dann wie folgt erklärt staatliche
autorität wird nicht mehr anerkannt
und ich glaube das trifft das ist ja
sehr gut als sie 1992 als junge
amtsrichter als erkennbar berufsanfänger
angefangen habe war es mir ein leichtes
eine strafverhandlung zu führen
mit 53 jahren im jahre 2017 traf ich auf
raichs bürger starts leugner ohne jeden
respekt auftreten der angeklagte und
zeugen schon wesentlich schwieriger war
die situation anfeindungen die
sogenannten sozialen netzwerken
die privaten bereich fotografieren und
verbreiten private szenen war nur eine
der unannehmlichkeiten denen man sich
ausgesetzt da und am meisten und am
ehesten trifft der verlust staatliche
autorität diejenigen die schon rein
optisch für jedermann repräsentieren die
uniformierte schutzpolizei mit ihren
einsatzfahrzeugen die als erste vor ort
sind ihren kopf hinhalten für diesen
staat und seine bürger nicht gerade
üppig bezahlt und in manchen
bundesländern auch nicht besonders gut
ausgerüstet riskieren gerade sie ihr
leben und das leben die körperliche
unversehrtheit anderer zu schützen
der präsident der bundespolizei die der
roman hat das im innenausschuss dieser
woche wie folgt erklärt junge
polizeibeamte und beamtinnen wird in
ihrer ausbildung beigebracht dass sie
dafür da sind recht und gesetz zur
geltung zu verhelfen und rechtsbrecher
dingfest zu machen um sie der justiz zu
übergeben
in stuttgart mussten genau diese jungen
beamten und beamtinnen feststellen dass
sie das nicht mehr konnte weil einer
nach amok dies vereitelte die lage war
außer kontrolle trotz des einsatzes
aller verfügbaren kräfte
neben der angst um das eigene leben oder
die körperliche unversehrtheit erzeugt
das bei polizisten und polizistinnen das
gefühl der hilflosigkeit eine
frustration die sich teilweise leider
auch im wahlverhalten niederschlägt also
tun wir doch bitte alles dafür dass
dieses gefühl der ohnmacht sich nicht
weiter verfestigt gesetze und straff
schärfung bei übergriffen gegen polizei
und rettungskräfte sind das eine hat der
abschreckende strafen für die verbrecher
in stuttgart sind die dringend
notwendige reaktion der justiz zur
verteidigung unserer rechtsordnung aber
ein ende
am ende wird das alles nichts nutzen
wenn in dieser gesellschaft nicht jeder
einzelne bereit ist recht und gesetz als
verbindlich zu betrachten dazu gehört
dass man die integrität andere
respektiert dass man auch ihr
andersartig
zeit respektiert dass man fremdes
eigentum achtet und dazu gehört auch
dass man bei der steuer nicht bescheid
nicht vorsätzlich zu schnell fährt oder
nicht größer baut als mann darf und so
weiter und so fort und so dazu gehört
dass man das staatliche gewaltmonopol
nicht ständig in frage stellt seine
repräsentanten ist mit misstrauens
überzieht und immer neue
kontrollmechanismen fordert und die
hürden für staatliche eingriffe nicht
immer höher sitzt jede staatliche
maßnahme unterliegt der kontrolle durch
die unabhängige justiz und das genügt
und diejenigen ihr recht und gesetz
verteidigen und an vorderster stelle
steht da unsere polizei dürfe nicht als
gegner sondern als das gesehen werden
was ist sinn als freund und helfer und
mit der vergleichsweise wenigen die das
alles nicht beachten wollen wird dieser
rechtsstaat schon fertig und die flüge
zum schluss hinzu wenn man ihn denn
lässt vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
nächster redner ist der kollege martin
hess fdp ow präsident verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn man die
heutige debatte zu den gewaltigsten
stuttgart verfolgt muss man eines
feststellen
bis auf die fdp weigern sich offenbar
alle fraktionen den kern des problems
klar und deutlich zu benennen
entweder sind sie wirklich dazu nicht in
der lage oder sie verweigern sich
schlicht der realität stuttgarts war
kein event der partyszene sondern ein
gewaltexzess von migranten und
linksextremisten von 37 festgenommenen
haben 22 einem migrationshintergrund
viele haben flüchtlings bezug auf den
tat videos sind die rufen allahu akhbar
facto system facto police klar und
deutlich zu hören wer hier einen
politischen hintergrund verneint der
ignoriert tatsachen islamisten und
linksextremisten haben sich in dieser
nacht zusammengetan um unseren
rechtsstaat zu destabilisieren und ich
sage gerade ihnen wie sie das immer
wieder mit leugnen ganz klar wenn wir
stuttgart jetzt nicht zum anlass nehmen
um ihr konsequent gegenzusteuern
dann wird auf unseren straßen immer mehr
chaos und gewalt herrschen und das
können und dürfen wir nicht zulassen
ich habe mit etlichen kollegen
gesprochen die in dieser nacht im
einsatz waren die gewalt und
zerstörungsorgien von stuttgart zeigen
für baden-württemberg eine völlig neue
qualität des hasses auf deutschland und
die polizei und die bürger und vor allem
die polizeibeamten sind es leid ständig
für ihr politikversagen den kopf
hinhalten zu müssen sparen sie sich ihre
lehren solidaritätsbekundungen und
sorgen sie in deutschland endlich für
mehr sicherheit stuttgart ist nämlich
nicht vom himmel gefallen
stuttgart ist die logische folge des
total versagens alle parteien in der
migrations in der integrations und in
der sicherheitspolitik
sitzen bis zum heutigen tage unsere
grenzen nicht lassen hunderte und
tausende islamisten staatsfeinde und
gewaltverbrecher in unser land no go
areas wie zb in discos oder leipzig
connewitz sind ebenfalls ihr werk über
jahrzehnte haben sie zugelassen dass
kleinkriminelle und linksextremisten in
unserem land nahezu ungestört ihr
unwesen treiben und anstatt linke gewalt
jetzt endlich konsequent zu bekämpfen
kooperieren sie allesamt mit
linksextremisten mittlerweile wie
vergessen auch zumindest auf länderebene
ja auch die cdu und mit all diesen
sicherheitsbedrohungen die sie selbst
geschaffen haben lassen sie unsere
polizei alleine ich sage es in aller
deutlichkeit ihrer heute wieder
vorgetragenen hohlen phrasen und
lippenbekenntnisse die können sie sich
sparen nicht an worten sondern an ihren
taten werden sie gemessen die kollegen
da draußen und genau dieses feedback
habe ich eins zu eins bekommen die
fühlen sich von ihnen gnadenlos im stich
gelassen
und das zeigt auch das verhalten des
innenministers in dieser woche wieder
zur ost kündigte an eine strafanzeige zu
erstatten gegen eine autorin die unsere
polizisten bundesweit menschen verachten
als abfall beleidigt hat wenige tage
später lässt er sich dann von der
kanzlerin davon abbringen
ein innenminister mit format mit den
schluss kraft und durchsetzungsvermögen
hätte sich ohne wenn und aber vor seine
beamten gestellt und selbstverständlich
anzeige erstattet und dass der minister
die ist es notwendig signal der
politischen rückendeckung für unsere
polizei nicht entsprechend ausgesendet
hat zeigt eindeutig wenn es darauf
ankommt lässt auch dort bundesminister
des innern die polizei im stich
die bürger haben ihre leeren
ankündigungen satz was deutschland jetzt
braucht das ist ein radikaler wandel in
der sicherheitspolitik und der
beinhaltet insbesondere folgende
elemente
erstens schluss mit dem generalverdacht
gegen unsere sicherheitskräfte wer
polizisten rassismus oder
rechtsextremismus unterstellt der
stadtpolizei feindliche stimmung und ist
für mangelnden respekt vor dem start und
für gewalt gegen polizeibeamte mit
verantwortlich zweitens klare politische
rückendeckung und zielführende
einsatzstrategien für unsere
sicherheitskräfte unsere polizei braucht
eine konsequente null toleranz strategie
mit klaren vorgaben für ein robustes
einschreiten bei dem typus von stuttgart
da hilft keine deeskalation da hilft
keine prävention da hilft keine
sozialarbeit sondern nur härter
zwangsmittel einsatz
drittens sofortiger effektiver
grenzschutz damit keine gewaltverbrecher
mehr als flüchtlinge einreisen können
und konsequente abschiebung aller
ausländischen straftätern
viertens schluss mit falscher toleranz
gegenüber von parallelgesellschaften
wer sich nicht integriert sondern
unseren staat aktiv bekämpft der hat in
unserem land nichts zu suchen
fünftens bekämpfen sie endlich den
linksextremismus verhindern sie das
antifa und co ethnische unruhen anheizen
um deutschland zu destabilisieren die
gruppen der antifa sind ausnahmslos zu
verbieten
diese maßnahme leitlinien er könne hier
auch ihre reden zeit ist abgelaufen und
das wort erfreulich jetzt den kollegen
der gelingt spd
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich habe glaube ich herrn heißt
jetzt gerade richtig verstanden wer sich
in diesem land nicht integriert und den
stark verkämpft hat in diesem land
nichts zu suchen bitte gehen sie denn
sie sind weder integriert noch in der
weise tragen sie zu diesem gemeinwesen
konstruktiv bei und sie bekämpfen diesen
staat motorisch insofern haben sie das
urteil über sich selbst gerade gefällt
es ist ja so wenn man sich selbst
zitiert ist dass entweder ein ausdruck
von genialität oder weisheit in meinem
fall ist es ein ausdruck von weisheit
und ich habe bei meiner letzten rede
gesagt für die afg ist der mensch nicht
zweck sondern mittel und nur stimmvieh
und sie haben wieder frau weiter in
ihrer schließlich schmierigen rede und
sie eben auch im jahr ketten und
variante genau das bewiesen für sie ist
der mensch nur mittel
ich selbst habe erlebt in den letzten
jahren und monaten wie die polizei auch
der staatsschutz an meiner seite stand
und bin dazu da für zutiefst dankbar und
empfinde deshalb es umso mehr
was für ein erbärmliches handeln und was
für eine erbärmliche erniedrigung diesen
polizistinnen polizisten in stuttgart
zuteil wurde
aber gerade weil das so ist weil sie das
erdulden mussten verdienen sie es gerade
nicht zum spielball ihrer dreckigen aus
spiel politik gegen menschen mit
migrations politikum
migrationshintergrund zu sein
das ist widerlich sie interessieren sich
nicht im geringsten für das schicksal
von polizisten polizisten sondern sie
sehen angesichts ihrer umfragewerte da
die letzte möglichkeit sich irgendwie
profilieren zu können aber deutschland
polizei ist klug genug auf diese falle
nicht hereinzufallen und sich nicht
ausspielen zu lassen
das was sie
wir präsentieren ist zutiefst unredlich
und ich nenne es parasitäre politik wie
schmarotzer nutzen sie so ein ernstes
vorgehen in stuttgart um daraus
politische geländegewinne zu ziehen
widerlich erbärmlich unredlich ist dass
man sieht in ihrem umkreis auf minsk
epics bilder und das muss man sich mal
vergegenwärtigen des nahen ostens und
nordafrikas und darüber ist geschrieben
partyszene wie nenne ich das blanken
rassismus sie haben hier eine aktuelle
stunde im namen vom blanken rassismus
gemacht und sie haben auch großartige
unterstützung das ist jetzt bitter für
uns das feststellen zu müssen
ich lese in tweets von herrn maßen
leider mal verfassungsschutzpräsident
und auch von der werte union dass man
sich verwehre gegen die ideologisierung
und instrumentalisierung des
antirassismus und dann steht da
stuttgart wäre doch der blick für
falsche toleranz und die ideologie der
unten gesellschaft wie verstrahlt und
ich muss auch sagen die heuchlerisch
kann man sein wenn man sich einerseits
gegen ideologie und instrumentalisierung
wendet und dann ein gipfel stück ein
meisterstück der instrumentalisierung
und ideologisierung auf wird und sie
sind in dieser tradition ja sie steigern
diese noch liebe kollegin kennen
es ist wenn wenn sie mir hätte vorwerfen
ist das für mich eine ehrenbezeichnung
so auch wie ihr hämischen applaus immer
für mich eine würdigung ist die ich sehr
stolz zugegen nehmen
aber da sie ja da sie ja so viel wert
auf deutsche traditionen an anstand
werden ich habe genau gehört als eine
kollegin freuen sagte er einige der
täter waren deutsche war der zwischenruf
deutscher pass das sagt alles für sie
ist deutsch nicht wer die deutsche
staatsangehörigkeit hat nein
für sie ist deutsch wer technisch
biologisch
drastisch wie auch immer deutsch ist und
damit stehen sie nicht auf dem boden
dieses grundgesetzes sie haben damit
fort er demonstranten gezeigt dass sie
sich nicht mit diesem land
identifizieren und dass sie am besten
dieses land verlassen wollen wie sie am
anfang ja selbst begründet haben ich
appelliere dringend an uns alle hier und
ich fand es deshalb auch suboptimal dass
wir kleine formen des
landtagswahlkampfes erlebt haben dass
wir solche reiz wie in stuttgart wir
haben welche erlebt in dijon und auch
den haare und anderswo nutzen für
politische kämpfe und für
parteipolitische spiele sicherheit wird
gebaut auf vertrauen und nicht auf
verdacht und angst und deshalb gebietet
es die würde dieses hauses und der
politik dass wir das nicht ausschlachten
für unsere zwecke weder für rassismus
noch für landtagswahlen vielen dank
nächster redner kollege alexander throm
cdu/csu sehr guter präsident werde
kolleginnen und kollegen polizei dein
freund und helfer
das habe ich in meiner kindheit gelernt
das war damals gesellschaftlicher
konsens in deutschland
heute müssen wir alle feststellen dass
der respekt vor unserer polizei
nachgelassen hat die angriffe auf die
polizei
zugenommen hat und insofern möchte ich
zunächst mal danke sagen an alle
polizistinnen und polizisten die am
letzten vorletzten samstag in stuttgart
ihren dienst vollbracht haben die unsere
werte geschützt haben sachwerte aber
auch personen menschen geschützt haben
und dabei ihr eigenes wohl ein stück
weit außer acht gelassen hat das ist
aufgabe von politik und für mich war es
unvorstellbar dass wir einen solchen
gewaltexzess haben können ohne dass es
dafür einen äußeren anlass gibt oder
dass es durch hooligans organisiert
wurde oder durch links oder
rechtsextremisten im rahmen einer
demonstration organisiert wurde sondern
ein kleiner marginaler anlass eines
solchen gewaltausbruch verursacht hat
und dann stelle ich mir schon die frage
warum passiert es ausgerechnet in
unserem sauberen in unserem liberalen
unseren fleißigen schattigen stuttgart
warum ausgerechnet dort und das hat mich
dann nach ein paar tagen vielleicht gar
nicht mehr so verwunderten herr kollege
özdemir
da müssen wir schon auch noch mal ein
bisschen in die vergangenheit
zurückgehen gerade von stuttgart die
letzten zehn jahre und die politischen
auseinandersetzungen die wir da hatten
das hat schon auch auswirkungen auf eine
stadt und ihre gesellschaft tun
sie wissen es ja ausgehend von stuttgart
21 da ist nicht alles optimal gelaufen
erster zweiter untersuchungsausschuss
ich war im zweiten
untersuchungsausschuss als
landtagsabgeordneter bei da hat man
einzelfälle zu general fällen gemacht
zum general vortag gegenüber der polizei
in baden württemberg und darüber hinaus
da haben manche ihr verhältnis zur
polizei klären wollen wir haben der
diskussion werden die diskussion gehabt
über die kennzeichnungspflicht herr
kollege özdemir wo sie misstrauen
gegenüber der polizei geführt haben wo
die polizistinnen polizisten das auch so
empfunden haben in baden württemberg und
wird das glücklicherweise verhindern
konnten und wir hatten jahrelang eine
diskussion über body camps zum schutz
der polizistinnen und polizisten die
grünen haben sich verweigert jetzt
konnte es eingeführt werden im übrigen
vom innenminister strobl gegen bedenken
aus der fdp und das einzige was heute
peinlich fahrbahn stück weiter an ihr
angriff auf den minister strobl herr
strasser die fdp ist ja
bekanntlicherweise für nichts
verantwortlich weil sie nirgendwo
verantwortung übernommen hat bzw
zugetragen bekommen hat dass man kann
man alles besser wissen ohne etwas
besser machen zu müssen und deswegen
hoffe ich liebe kollegen kollegen gerade
auch der grünen dass sie ihr verhältnis
zur polizei klären ihre kollegin
michaela der heute nach einem interview
der faz gesagt wir mussten als grüne
aber erst lernen dass die polizei ein
positiver faktor in der gesellschaft ist
ich glaube nur irland prozess ist noch
nicht abgeschlossen war erst vor wenigen
wochen haben wir über einen polizei
beauftragten auf antrag der grünen
diskutiert insofern sollten sie dann
noch mal in sich gehen um wirklich die
unterstützung für unsere polizei für
unsere sicherheitskräfte zu
gewährleisten und ich möchte schließen
mit einem tweet von gestern der mich
sehr geärgert hat fried ist future
weimar schreibt feuerwehr und
rettungsdienst retten menschen die
polizei diskriminiert
mordet moped prügelt lasst uns aufhören
die beiden in einem aufzug als helfer zu
titulieren
stattdessen sollten wir antifa und
migrant ifa wertschätzen
deutschland hat ein polizei problem bis
gerade vorhin keine reaktion von
schreibers for future deutschland ich
habe begonnen mit dem satz die polizei
dein freund und helfer und was wir
damals in meiner kindheit jugend gelernt
haben lassen sie uns alle zusammenstehen
zusammen helfen dass wir unseren kindern
und jugendlichen diesen satz wieder
beibringen herzlichen dank letzter
redner in dieser aktuellen stunde ist
kollege doktor volker ullrich cdu csu
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren zum abschluss dieser
aktuellen stunde will noch mal betonen
was es eigentlich geht um die frage wie
eine gesellschaft das zusammenleben
organisiert wird und welche regeln und
haltungen für uns alle gelten damit ein
respektvoller umgang möglich ist und
weiter gedeihen kann
und dazu gehört dass es in dieser
gesellschaft keine toleranz für gewalt
gibt gewalt ist kein mittel
auseinandersetzung gewalt ist etwas was
wir achten müssen und wir müssen auch
darauf schauen wie gewalt entsteht sie
entstehen auch durch gedanken die zur
sprache werden und sprache die zu hass
wird und hass der in taten um schlägt
deswegen muss es für alle demokraten
klar und deutlich sein dass wir gewalt
ächten meine damen und herren und damit
wir die ächtung von gewalt durchsetzen
können brauchen wir in unserem staat
eine starke grundrechts gebundene
polizei und diese polizei
hat unseren respekt und unsere rückhalt
verdient es ist klar dass sich die
polizei auf uns verlassen kann
wir schützen die die uns schützen
und ich bitte sie einfach auch mal einen
abend wie in stuttgart aus den augen
eines polizeibeamten zu sehen
im mittleren oder auch im gehobenen
dienst sind junge menschen die nicht
wissen was sie erwartet
die aber aus erzählungen befürchten dass
sie angespuckt werden dass sie
angerempelt werden dass vielleicht
jemand ein messer zog deswegen haben wir
die polizei auch immer stärker mit
stichfesten westen ausstatten müssen es
sind polizeibeamte die nicht wissen wie
eine explosive alkoholgetränke stimmung
sich auch sie ganz persönlich auswirken
wird
und wer auch immer so einen dienst macht
eine ganze nacht lang der hat unseren
respekt verdient des weges und deutlich
zu machen dass wir hinter diesen
polizeibeamten stehen
wir müssen auch deutlich machen dass
stuttgart nicht irgendein gewaltexzess
war und auch alle beschädigungen in
richtung exzesse einer party szene sind
völlig falsch am platz
es handelt sich hier um delikte wie
landfriedensbruch
die brandstiftungen wie schwere
körperverletzung das sind schwere
straftaten die der rechtsstaat mit allem
nachdruck aufklären und verfolgen muss
aber zum rechtsstaat gehört auch dass
wir uns zunächst einmal fragen wer waren
die täter
was denn ihre motive dass wir den
habhaft werden und dass wir sie dann
verurteilen
eine vorverurteilung ist nicht etwas was
rechtsstaatlichen grundsätzen entspricht
und was sich in der tag befremdlich fand
ich muss nochmal ansprechen
war diese unterscheidung zwischen
deutschen und passt deutschen das ist
ein völkischer gedanke von dem wir
gehofft haben alle miteinander dass in
diesem wohnhaus nie mehr zu hören ist
aber ich bitte uns auch alle dass wir
diese konsequenz nach stuttgart
differenziert betrachten und es sind
noch viele von kollegen frei angefangen
über kollegen müller bis kollegen throm
interessante ansätze gegeben
wir müssen über die frage diskutieren
welche rolle spielt alkohol
wir müssen auch darüber sprechen welche
müssen auch darüber sprechen welche
rolle spielen gewaltig gewalt
legitimieren den normen welche rolle
spielen gewalt legitimieren den normen
gerade auch bei jungen männern
auch diese frage müssen wir diskutieren
ich glaube dass wir umfassende
kriminalpräventiven konzepte in unseren
städten brauchen ein starker rückhalt
eine ordentliche ausstattung unserer
polizei ist das eine und
präventionskonzepte sind das andere
wir gehen das problem
gesamtgesellschaftlich an wir wollen
nicht gruppen gegeneinander ausspielen
sondern wir wollen eine effektive lösung
haben die auf dem boden des
grundgesetzes steht das ist unsere
haltung dazu und ich kann abschließend
sagen wir stehen hinter unsere polizei
weil wir wissen dass dadurch freiheit
sicherheit und grundrechte verwirklicht
werden
die aktuelle stunde beendet